الان الى اثيوبيا حيث بدات القوه الارتريه
الانسحاب من اقليم شمل البلاد وذلك تنفيذا
لاتفاقيه بريتوريا المبرم بين اديس ابابا
وجبه التيفاي
كبيره من القوه الارثريه
وعدي
وحاله محلها قوات الجيش الافريقي
وهي تتجه نحو الحدود
مع بدء قوه جبهه تسليم اسلحتها الثقيله
وبانتشار الفريقا للمراقبين وافراد من
الجيش الفيدراليه في مناطق مختلفه من
الاقليم
وقد رحب وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يطالب
لينكن بالتقدم في تنفيذ اتفاقيه وقت
الاعمال العيدائيه في اثيوبيا
حقوق الانسان الدوليين كما جدد في اتصال
مع رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي احمد التزام
واشنطن بدعم عمليه السلام التي يقودها
الاتحاد الافريقي في شمال اثيوبيا
حول هذا الموضوع معنا الان من هذه الساعه
بابا مراسل الجزيره حسن رزاق المزيد من
التفاصيل حسن حول مجريات الاحداث بدا
انسحاب القوات الارتريه من اقليم ومن ثم
هذا الاتصال الهاتفي
بينكن وابي احمد
اتصال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي باحمد يعكس
هذه اهميه هذه الخطوه وهي بدا القوات
الارتريه الانسحاب من اقليم والعوده الى
الاراضي الارتياب ازدهار طبعا اهميه هذه
الخطوه تكمل بانها كانت احد ابرز اسباب او
همم كانت الكثير من البنود في الاتفاقيه
السلامه الممرضه بين الجبهه
والحكومه الليبيه معلقه بضروره انسحاب
القوات الاتريه حيث ان اعجبها التجراء
اشاره ان بدا تسليم الاسلحه الثقيله
واستكمال كافه الترتيبات الامنيه مرهونه
بانسحاب القوات الاثريه وايضا وجود القوات
الاثريه في الداخل كان مسار جبل سياسي
وادبلوماسي من قبل المجتمع الدولي خاصه
الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبالتالي اتصال او وزير
الخارجيه بابي احمد يعكس اهميه طبعا
الزياره حتى هذه اللحظه ليس هناك اي تصريح
رسمي الى الحكومه الاثيوبيه لكن اريتريا
وفي صحيفتها الرسميه اصدرت ما يسمى
بالتعليق السياسي اشارت فيه ان الجيش
الاريتري بحسب وصف الصحيفه احماء اثيوبيا
من الصومل ومن ال ال التفتت بحسب مع شعرنا
الجيش الاثيوبي كان ساعد الجيش الاثيوبيه
في صد هجمه
استهدفت القاعده الشماليه في نوفمبر عام
2020 التي كانت تهدف بحسب الصحيفه الى قلب
نظام الحكم فبالتالي هذا التزام نشر
الصحيفه الرسميه هذا التعليق مع بدء
القوات الاثريه من الاتحاد هو اشاره بشكل
غير مباشر انه وجود الجيش الامريكان لهدف
معين والان يتم الانسحاب من الاعراض التي
بعد ان اكملت هذا الهاتف حسب اشاره
الصحيفه على اي حال ازدهار ليس هناك صور
رسميه من الانسحاب لكن تتوارد من همم
شهداء عيان وصور ولقطات وسحب الجيش من
مناطق
بالامثله مدينه تاشيره الجيش الامريكي لتر
منها بالكامل وتم ال- ال- حلول الجيش
الفيدرالي الاثيوبي مكانه بالتالي هناك
خطوات مستمره في سحب الجيش قالت لك كافه
قواتي واسلحه الثقيله من هذه المنطقه
التنفيدا لاتفاقيه السلام التي كانت احد
ابرز
شروط استكمال هذه اتفاقي وهو انسحاب
الجزائر
حسب الرزاق شكرا جزيلا لك